welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your captain definition and this video
were breaking down the third episode of
Picard our mission is to boldly go where
no one has gone before
and give our thoughts on the new entry
as well as what could be happening in
the future
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the third
episodes plot it's Easter eggs and what
we thought of it as a whole we will be
engaging with heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to catch the
show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos and Piccard every
week and without the way let's get into
our breakdown at Picard episode 3 ok so
just a quick recap of Picard episode 2
after the death of data's door a dodge
picaud made it his mission to track down
her twin sister solji picaud wanted to
set out into the stars to locate her
however not only was he diagnosed with
eremitic syndrome and Alzheimer's like
disease
he was also declared unfit for space
travel and grounded by Starfleet the
episode ended with us discovering that
there was a Romulan mole within
Starfleet Picard had to call on an old
friend to get off the planet episode 3
the end is the beginning is pretty much
centered around this notion and Picard
exemplifies this statement in many ways
the end of his career with Starfleet was
pretty much the beginning of a new
direction and this is mirrored
throughout many characters in the entry
there's a real phoenix rising from the
ashes motif in episode 3 no it is pretty
much one big info dump I did still enjoy
it I'll say right off the bat that this
is probably my least favorite of the
three so far because it seems to be
dragging its heels but you can tell that
going forward everything put in place
here will pay off the end of this
episode is very much at the beginning
you could say and yeah you don't come
here for the jokes really do you anyway
we once more open with a flashback to
the synthetic uprising on Mars as we
learn last week this was carried out on
first contact day and the date was
purposely picked to ruin any goodwill
that the federation had towards the
holiday we did theorize at last time
something was uploaded to the Droid f8
aka
fate who started off the attack and in
the introduction we can clearly see code
being added into his programming I did
slow this down to see if there were any
hidden messages in it but unfortunately
it was just the usual camelcase
lettering and semicolons and colons that
come with computer based languages so
now there was no execute order from the
Romulans at least that we know about
again to my fan theory on now in just a
bit though we then jumped to Starfleet
headquarters 14 years ago to see Picard
and one of the new characters in the
episode meeting this is Raffy who you
learn was his former first officer on
the USS parity do turbo codes
resignation
Rafi ended up losing her career - and
she's carried a lot of resentment over
it for the past decade and a half the
intro opens up how much the burning of
Mazda stabilized the galaxy and sort of
gave Starfleet the excuse to not
evacuate the Romulans in the new Canon
prequel comic book Star Trek four card
countdown we learn that before the
attack on Mars Picard and his new ship
the Verity were asked to evacuate 10,000
Romulans however upon arriving there he
and Rafi were taken hostage by the
Romulan government and they discovered
that there were actually five million
inhabitants on the planet that needed to
be removed they learned that the
Romulans only wanted their own people
taken off the world in the wave of the
supernova and of course Picard protested
this the two defeated the evil Romulan
leaders and returned to Earth with the
news of the incoming disaster this
kick-started the events that led up to
the show and that should be you all
fully up to speed Starfleet on the whole
has often been painted out as this
perfect system but Picard is really
dismantling that notion Patrick Stewart
in the run-up to the show did say he
took on the project because he believed
it to be tackling the current world we
live in in the wake of brexit and Donald
Trump's presidency this opening
definitely hammers that home with the
government being more interested about
looking after themselves than being open
to helping other people who may end up
emigrating to earth I don't want to get
too political because I don't believe
that either side is a fully figured out
but Star Trek has always tackled ideas
like this and obviously Picard would be
no different we jump to the Vasquez
rocks in the present and see Picard
breaking down what's happened so far in
the series just show other videos of
Picard
I've got your back Admiral Clancy is
mentioned from episode 2 and it's clear
that Rafi had run-ins with her as well
Rafi has pretty much stepped away from
the prestige of Starfleet and now lives
in the desert by herself
she still wears an army type cap but
there's very much a feeling of a
self-sustained Malaysian who rather than
a government-sanctioned body I kind of
got flashbacks of Sarah Connor in
Terminator 2 from her outfit and it's
very much a feeling that she's exiled
herself from here we journey back to the
Borg cube and are reintroduced to Hugh
if you watch the next generation you may
remember that he was a former Borg drone
that Picard and the crew met in the show
he was critically injured during the
episode and taken back to the
enterprise-d where he was cut off from
the collective the character never knew
what it was to be like this away from
the hive through the crew he learned
that humans did not want to be
assimilated which contradicted what he'd
been told he was given his name instead
of his previous number two three six
eight and developed his own
individuality we learn that he has been
working aboard the station and mentoring
Sochi Sochi is adept at talking to the
nameless and this is due to her machine
abilities which she is currently still
unaware of we learned that the Borg had
been assimilating Romulans and it is
possible that she has been brought in to
learn about their past and hidden
mythology sorry sorry I hate that word
through knowing that Romulans had a fall
store traditionally in their homes
she's so able to gain entry by bypassing
the false front that the mystic
character puts on we learn that they are
trying to create a sort of shed religion
to unite everyone and I'll get into this
later in the recap back on earth Picard
confirms one of Raffi's conspiracy
theories that is the Tal Shiar and
Starfleet must be working together in
order for the former to operate so also
here that we get confirmation of the
theory that the Romulans sabotage their
own rescue and allowed the attack on
Mars to go ahead in order to create a
false flag attack we still don't know
why this was carried out however it is
possible that we were told this last
week by Clancy be cast your mind back
klancy did tell Picard that there were
14 systems thinking of leaving the
Federation this was over the refugee
crisis due to the effort they would have
to put in into rest
the Romulans we do know this synth
uprising gave them the perfect excuse
not to help the Romulans and thus they
remained we didn't hear anything extra
after this conversation about the
systems leaving so it's a safe bet to
assume that they stayed we do know that
the Romulans hate synthetics and perhaps
they hacked into them in order to make
the rest of the galaxy join them in
banning the androids the fact that their
planet was on the brink of destruction
during this would give them the perfect
alibi and personally I believe that's
what happened before we get into the
rest of the video I just wanna let you
know we're giving away a free copy of
dr. sleep to one random subscriber all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Picard in the comments section below the
winner it's gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February and the Celt be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part anyway Picard finally has
a ship and he meets captain Rios who
seems a bit messed up Rios has a
hologram that is sort of the voice in
his head
I don't know I don't know why he doesn't
just have him out there getting stabbed
and said maybe maybe he can't leave the
ship or something obvious yeah I'm
Captain Obvious over here anyway
Picard sees that Rios is reading the
tragic sense of life this is a
philosophical book and has gained a lot
of prominence of the heirs and is seen
as one of the knowledge bases of
civilization and due to its importance
the book states that if one were to live
in eternal life then life itself would
become meaningless thus death gives us
purpose this could be mirrored in Picard
who as we know is living on borrowed
time I guess you could say learning that
his life was about to end gave it a new
beginning the like buttons right there
thank you very much similar to Picard
Rios has been cast aside by Starfleet
and forgotten about however old habits
die hard and Rios clearly has a
difficulty leaving it all behind and
still keeps everything in order
Rios clearly admired the captain but
after the death of his own several years
prior he doesn't want to potentially
lead to another one going off into the
great beyond
Picard gives a really touching monologue
on Chateau Picard and realizes that he
never belonged there it's amongst the
cosmos that is his home the Jaguar show
up looking to assassinate
but luckily for him they're no match for
a guy pushing 80 and his mates
dr. Agnes to shows up out of the blue to
save them and is possible that she was
aware of this attack and put in as a
plant by the Federation we do see
Commodore owl from last time talking to
her at one point in the episode so this
is definitely possible though she
divulges all of this to Picard it could
be a double bluff to win his trust
though I do think she would switch sides
eventually she join him should it come
down to it that's my theory on the
character's true intentions here the
Romulan mystic remembers Shoji from
tomorrow and says that they've met
before we learned that she was on the
last ship ever assimilated by the cube
but something went wrong now it could be
possible that Rhonda did not meet solji
but rather dodge the episode ends with
us learning that dodge and so she have
been labeled as destroyers and that the
jack roush disintegrates upon uttering
this it's possible that due to Shoji
being the meld between synthetics and
organics that she is seen as the
destruction of pure life in the galaxy
obviously the Romulans hate synthetics
so they would see this as being a
destroyer of their way of life that's
just my theory but make sure you leave
yours below Shoji speaks to a mother who
is clearly a Romulan hologram and she
tells her that dodge is okay the
Romulans have clearly manipulated this
entire thing and we see the bad boys
sister and brother team up meet up at
the end also is it just me that finds it
funny that you can sneak in as Star
Fleet by trimming your eyebrows and
changing years no I'm just me anyway
it's clear that the easy way is wearing
thin and that they will be more forceful
soon so hopefully we will get their
endgame before too long the episode ends
with Picard and the group heading to
free cloud to track down Bruce Maddox
Raffy has discovered this and it is
possible that this could be where the
nest of synthetics all we did hear last
episode that there was a secret location
of synths and with Maddox heading out
into the galaxy to create a new data it
is possible that this is the location
the episode ends with Picard saying
engage and the next generation theme
playing and yeah I did get a bit
teary-eyed and some goosebumps and then
nostalgia it always gets to you those
were the days clearly they are
recruiting
new members of the team next time no I
did feel like this episode was a bit
slower I am still fully on board with it
I'm surprised Picard is getting as much
hate as it is because I'm massively
enjoying it and hey hopefully you're
liking the recaps too now obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts on the
episode so let me know in the comments
below and if you enjoyed this video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our breakdown from last
week if you missed it
we've now analyzed the first three
episode so if you want to quit catch up
or missed anything then that's the
playlist to watch if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below you get access to content early
and can also suggest new videos and
breakdowns and we massively appreciate
it if you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at Definition
YT or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
news on the channel so hopefully we see
over there very soon this is the channel
for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
you